العاب الفيديو لم تعد مجرد وسيله تسميته
بل لها بطولات يجني ابطالها جوائز قيمه
مبتكر منها الجيل الجديد مهنه مربحه فهناك
الملايين يتابعون يوتيوبرز لانهم
يشاركونهم مهاراتهم في الالعاب ويمنحونهم
فرصه لاعبي معهم وفي هذا المجال
لم الفتيات نصيب كبير من المشاركه والشهره
ولكن لحسن الحب التقيت اليوم باحدى
اللاعبات التي ستمنحنا فرصه حامل هذا
العالم انا هبه الله
ده الشخص اللي بيطلع لايف همم ايا كانت
المنصه ايه للناس بيشارك معاهم الحاجه
اللي هو بيعملها شخص بيلعب لعبه معينه
فبيطلع لايف بيستريم اللعبه دي للناس
يلعب معهم يعني يدخلهم معاهم وهكذا في ناس
بتعتبر خلاص
رياضه الكترونيه لان هي خلاص بقى
انت رايح تلعب يا عم لعب الاطفال دي وبتاع
كان زمان زي بالضبط كره القدم
اخذها بقى ايه اتجاه ثاني عايز يحترف
ويتمرن كل يوم يخش نادي وفريق والناس
تشوفه كويس في فريق ثاني يشتريه بالضبط ده
بيحصل في الرياضه الالعاب الالكترونيه
البطولات تبيها اشكال والوان في منها
بطولات بتتعمل من الشركه نفسها الشركه
الام بقى بتاعت اللعبه دي بقى البطوله
الاساسيه وفيها بطولات بتتعمل يعني سايبر
مثلا عايز يعمل البطوله للعبه دي للناس
اللي موجودين في السعوديه بيلعبوا ازاي
حاجه اسمها لاندا ايه يعني هيلعبوا على
ارض الواقع هم الخليج بيبقى من خمسه خمس
كراسي وخمس كراسي ثانيين بالاجهزه بتاعتها
بكل حاجه وهما الفريق ده بيلعب والفريق
قاعد الناحيه الثانيه بيلعب وشاشه كبيره
وراء دي العرض احنا بقى بنشوف اللعب بنشوف
الماتش هو ده الحدث اللي هيحصل قريب ان
انا ساده جدا بصراحه يعني اي حد مهتم
بالجيم عامه هيبقى حادد ان هو يشوف ان
الفرق بتلعب قدام بعض قدامه زي مثلا اللي
بيشجع كوره همم غير اللي بيتفرج على
التليفزيون غير لما يحضر الماتش الثاني في
جوائز قايمه طبعا للبطولات دي لان هي زي
ما بيقول لك اصلا اصلا بتوع العالميه
الرسميه في مصر يعني مش هيعملوا حدث ده
كله على على فكه يعني
[موسيقى]